welcome to another episode of chess
openings explained
I'm Jonathan Krantz and this is the show
where we take the views the openings
that you want to see on YouTube and I
explain them for you but today I chose
the Scotch game mostly because it's a
Ryan Chester favorite Ryan Chester of
course being the club manager here at
the st. Louis chess club so I will go
over there real quick and I think the
first person that sent it in the first
name that I saw there's a couple people
that requested the Scotch was Namco who
said if I might be so bold to ask for a
video that delves into the Scotch
opening to which I reply yes you can be
so bold and we'll get right to it
so the Scotch happens after E 4 E 5 the
King's pawn opening and after Knight f3
knight c6 black just defends the pond
the most popular moves here are the
reuleaux Pez or the Italian game but
today we're going to look into the
Scotch which in a lot of ways is a very
reasonable move
you know White's plan on move 1 after he
play d4 his next plan was he was going
to play d4 if black did nothing so when
black stops him from playing d4 he just
tries to get in anyway and now okay he
gets to move d4 in which is nice because
now these bishops are going to find good
homes there are some people that think
it's a bit too early to release this
tension here in the center just now
black is going to take this pawn
okay which is why some people it's more
popular to go for like the Rui Lopez or
something like that but I think this is
a very underestimated opening I think a
lot of people just kind of brush off the
Scotch
and as my prep for the lecture I played
a bunch of blitz games with this against
people my own rating and better and it
seems like they mostly don't know what
to do it's White's third most popular
move here and I think it surprises a lot
of people and okay the move we're going
to focus on today our two future games
are going to feature the obvious move
you capture on d4 and this is the scotch
game but it's worth pointing out in this
that in addition to that move there are
at least two different gambit lines that
are a lot of fun and I'm really exciting
if you like to play that kind of chess
and those moves are Bishop to c4 the
Scotch gambit and c3 which will go into
the goring gambit I will check out this
one first it's okay so white is offering
upon and you don't have to accept but
for interests sake we'll go ahead and
we'll check this out
and white can very easily just take back
this pawn but the most exciting way is
to offer a double pawn sacrifice with a
move Bishop to c4 alright so here we
have it the goring gambit much like its
cousin the Danish gambit
they often transpose you can get a very
exciting positions where white ends up
giving up two pawns in exchange for
really active pieces so all right and
I've had students ask me should I play
this opening because theoretically white
is losing here so some people don't like
to have losing positions but you can
learn a lot from playing lines like this
if you've never explored them because
you get to learn a lot about attacking a
lot about tactics a lot about how to mix
defense with the attack so I think for a
lot of people if you play a lot of blitz
games online this is a great blitz
weapon to try to learn a bit more about
how to take the initiative use your
active pieces and crush your opponent
because it's really difficult over the
board or you know online over the board
to to figure out the best way to defend
a sample continuation would be to first
check and make sure that this knight has
to block in the Bishop White's big Trump
is he's got these these monster bishops
here the Queen is on this awesome
diagonal so he's getting a lot of
pressure these pieces are getting ready
to come in for an attack so black will
normally just try to get his pieces out
as quickly as possible the check helps
them gain a tempo and now all right
black attacks the e pawn so white will
usually defend it and just to give you
an idea of the most aggressive
continuation white here can Castle
queenside so again your computer is
going to tell you that white is lost but
in reality why it's always going to win
this game if you know you're of a
certain rating
because it's very difficult to defend
this over the board right now why just
trying to play the move e5 when black
can even allow it we'll just look at
this line allowing a5 attacking the
knight so when the knight moves the most
aggressive move again is to sacrifice
another pawn with the move h4 giving the
g5 square for your knight so you're
starting to create some threats on the
th pawn so after black captures you
force black to make a positional
weakness on the King side this gives you
something to attack and after you know
moves like this you're really really
trying to mate the black king so you
notice these these Knights are in prime
position at some point you might play
the move h5 open the H file at the
proper time f3 or f4 might be really
useful and you're going in for an
all-out attack so this is a ton of fun
to play I wouldn't recommend it in real
you know over the board games that are
rated but you know when you're playing
for fun this is a great opening to learn
a lot about you know different ways to
to attack your opponent so okay so
that's what an exciting way to play it
will be our future of the day though the
other way to play it for this position
if you want to play a gambit is the
Scotch gambit which you're not giving
away as many pawns in this line but it
has a lot of different possible ways
that black can continue very popular is
like a move like Bishop to c5 which will
often transpose to some lines of the
gioco piano for example after this
continuation we get a really popular
line that people might know and there's
possibilities for some excitement here
the most exciting is you know you've
sacrificed several ponds and if black is
a little bit too daring and he tries to
go for four too much the safest
continuation is taking with the bishop
and then castling and playing d5 but if
it gets really greedy this is actually
known to be really good for white so
black shouldn't be able to play this way
now these threads and the King on this
open file here is really bad news also
we're attacking the bishop so if you you
know gluttonously take the rook you're
going to end up in a lot of trouble here
for example
um okay moves like this we're starting
to really get to them and okay you can
imagine in a position like this it's
needless to say whites having all the
fun here so something like that is
possible so there's better ways to play
that for black but that's okay
so yeah Knight f6 is probably the most
common move there's even this check
which is okay it's not really thought to
be the best way but now you can get kind
of an improved version of The Goring
gambit we looked at because of this
position you're allowed to Castle so if
black really wants to win all your your
pawns here okay well now this is sort of
an improved variation of before okay so
we'll offer just a one more line here in
the Scotch gambit the knight to f6 line
and castling has its own line of theory
we've transposed now into the two
Knights defense with an early d4 so the
most testing way is to play the move e5
of course yet castling was fine that's
its own thing and now normally when they
play e5 in a position like this and
there's a bishop on c4 black will almost
universally respond with the move d5
attacking the bishop and giving this
knight a nice square on e4 that he can
jump into so after the bishop moves we
can imagine the knight jumping in and
okay now we can regain our pawn on d4
and after some trades like this we get
some some normal position and to be
honest I kind of prefer black in these
sorts of positions because we'll take it
just a bit farther we'll go along the
main line and it's kind of funny what
white does here first he plays f3 and
then he plays f4 so we got the move f4
in with some tempo made the knight
bounce back and forth
after a few more developing moves now
we're possibly threatening you know to
move this this Knight somewhere and
we'll take you know trade the dark
squared bishop s' so okay after a few
more moves
now these pawns are going to start
moving down the board pretty quickly
here so they kick the white pieces
around and okay something like this it's
up for the players to decide whether you
know doubling the pawns here actually is
a threat
you know why can't allow it or he can
play the the most common move which is
to attack the Queen and okay this is
just an example so good continuation for
white would be you know to bring this
rook in somewhere or even play the
immediate f5 knowing that there's a you
know some some tricks based on
discovered checks here you know you can
take this or you can move here and
there's some discovered tricks so this
is you know one popular way that you can
play the Scotch gambit well that's not
going to be our main focus today I just
thought I'd introduce it because the
Scotch is really rich in different
possibilities and it can mean a lot of
different things to different people for
some it's a really aggressive opening
there's a lot of tactics even in the
very opening that both players should
know about and okay for some people it's
a very positional opening there's a lot
of ways you can play and really squeeze
your opponent but today we're focusing
on taking on d4 this is the mainline now
the two most popular moves here are
Bishop to c5 which is sort of the main
line that we're going to focus most on
today the other you know another normal
continuation is Knight to f6 so we'll
talk about them in turn worthy of
mention is the Czech Bishop to b4 which
most people will attribute to Tony miles
he kind of popularized this line but if
you're a st. Louis person you might
attribute it to Julian Pro laïkó who's
in China right now giving him away all
the secrets of how to refute the Scotch
so he's still missed I mean the point of
this move is that to provoke c3 and
you'll get some lines just like the
Bishop to c5 lines we're going to look
at in just a moment except for now white
doesn't have the c3 square for his
knight and that's what black is arguing
that this is a big plus for him so a
sample continuation Bishop e3 with a
threat if you you know are little little
too careless what will white play here
exactly yep you'll take the night
there's a discovered attack here you're
threatening the Queen so okay after you
you take back
you drop your bishop so okay so instead
normally black will move his Bishop and
this tricky move is part of this
variation so you know you're trying to
trade the dark squared bishop s'
normally black trades but g6 we'll look
at in just a second might also be a good
move and what tends to happen in these
positions is we get sort of a Maroc C
bind with white let's at least the main
way to play this the point is we're
going to play the move c4 we're gonna
play Knight to c3 so fans of the the
maroc C bind might enjoy playing this
variation you'll get a sample like this
it's worth mentioning that in this
position g6 is also a possible move the
idea is now white will be the one
trading and all right black is going to
hope for some counter play along the a
file and you know people will develop in
the same sort of manner and you know
again so we're it's a let's protect our
fun but yeah so the play will develop in
the same sort of manner and you know
okay the Knights going to c3 and again
we have AM Roxy bind the only difference
being that you know Black has the open a
file which he can try to use and this
binding normally is just going to be you
know white being slightly better for a
long long time it is hard for both sides
to do anything but some people like to
be better for a long time it's a good
feeling
and with that we'll jump into the games
that will look more at the the mainline
theory here okay this first game is a
game played between Carlson and Peter
Lecco and it was played in Nanjing in a
2009 and Carlson had an excellent
tournament that year if you don't
remember it it was a double round-robin
there were six players and Carlson
scored eight out of ten so you know we
like to think around here Fabiano
Caruana he had an excellent Sinquefield
cup he got seven in a row Carlson has
also had some pretty good tournaments
and he was 18 at the time and okay so a
fantastic tournament for him was this
one and in his round
one game he got off to a big win and
okay so we got the scotch and he didn't
play any of the gambits he just played
the main line and the main move that
we're going to look at Bishop to c5 so
attacking the knight for a second time
now it is possible to take this knight
and black can take back that's a fine
move but he doesn't have to does anyone
know what the other possible move is
here awesome
yeah Queen f6 with a really big threat
so if you know your your scholars mate
all right you notice that there's a big
threat of checkmate here and all right
so that will force white to you know put
his queen some more silly in front of
his bishop which is a one very playable
line and you know sometimes they'll play
Knight to f3 which is also kind of funny
because the point of taking the night
when you took here on c6 was you were
going to double their pawns so if you
play this variation you know black can
just take back he doesn't have to
capture the Queen's but in this
situation you know you doubled their
pawns but they doubled yours which kind
of means why did you you play that in
the first place
so this line isn't as popular but it is
still very playable there's there I mean
thousands of games so it's it's worth
looking into if you're interested but uh
the main line is Bishop to e3 simply
protecting the night and again so now we
want to remember that when this Bishop
comes to e3 we have the same sorts of
trick as before you know if you're
careless you're going to realize that
you're dropping a bishop so that is a
threat unlike the other variation you
don't have to play Bishop to b6 you can
play what a lako played which is Queen
to f6 attacking d4 for a third time and
okay asking white what he's going to do
he should probably support his knight a
very bad move for example would be
Knight to b5 now okay you might think
well when your queen moved away I'm
attacking the C pawn now when you're
Queen moves the C pawn is unprotected
but black actually
a really nice continuation here he can
just trade bishops threatening checkmate
so you'll have to take and then before
defending his C pawn he can give this
Czech forced you to weaken your King
side a little bit more and then always
play Queen to d8 and here it's an
excellent decision in whites pawns RMS
and the bishop on the knight on b5 his
expedition was useless so okay so that's
why in the game we saw the move c3 okay
and now black is getting ready to play
the equalizing move d5 so a lot of times
white will let them play it for example
they'll just play a move like g3 and
then they'll be lines with d5 and very
often it's really common in the Scotch
the white will at least initially gambit
the pond for example a popular
continuation is here and then we'll
regain this with a knight in a moment so
sometimes they'll take this night for
example and they'll try to defend this
and all right so this is one one way to
play this position and usually this
happens and all right white has an
isolated pawn but he has two bishops so
this is one playable way but that that
wasn't chosen by Carlsen he picked
what's actually the d most popular which
is Bishop to c4 just preventing d5
altogether
alright this does allow one interesting
continuation that's the main line and
was played here Knight to e5 attacking
the bishop and whenever black gets to
play a move like d6 perhaps this night
will be able to jump into a g4 and
harass this Bishop so instead of going
to be three white will usually put is a
bishop on e2 just defending the g4
square preemptively now this move a
double attack and this is very common
white is always looking to sacrifice the
C pawn in this line so here what was
played was castles now who can tell me
what happens if black takes this pawn
because he didn't do it he played d6
what should white play if black takes
here there's two correct answers f3
removing the defender of your bishop is
not the best 92 yes this is one of the
very you know this is one of the good
moves
perhaps it the easiest understand is a
knight to b5 which is also a winning
move
you can insert Knight to d2 with a
similar play the point is now that your
castled you can make these threats
because if you ever take this bishop
well now i'm castled so you're not
threatening checkmate on f2 anymore and
so this will just lose in exchange you
do have some compensation I mean this
Knight is sort of trapped in there but
it's it's not really what you'd want to
do notice also if I play here defending
everything what should what's your white
play here there's another to move
sequence here so if you want to pause
your video at home
first we can take and who sees that the
follow-up here come on you got to see it
yeah Queen D for a double attack on the
the Queen at night and if the Queen
takes the you know the Queen's they're
exchanged well now I'm threatening this
and I'm threatening your night so I'm
going to win material here so for that
reason the e pawn is untouchable and yes
as Ben Simon said you can also start
with the move like Knight - D - and your
next move is going to be Knight to b5
okay and so yes that's the kind of thing
that you want to look for in the
scotches can I kind of gambit my e pawn
so he realized that and now for a long
time you know the way to play it was the
simple f3 and be really solid but during
this time Carlson was working with Gary
Kasparov who in the 1990s he made this
variation very popular and so perhaps
because he was working together he you
know he probably has a lot of research
on this position he did his homework for
this game and he played the very
aggressive f4 which now black should
take this and he's threatening to take
this with check so you have to do
something with your bishop and okay so
he went back and okay so you've given up
a pawn but you're going to get some some
play here the immediate issues what are
you going to do with your knight in
black here traded on d4 this move is too
greedy and how is this move refuted
it's very similar to the last one it's
the same same sort of idea yeah so still
night to be five threatening this this
pawn here and also you know you're
threatening to move this Bishop and
unleash an attack on the Queen so even
if you trade here for example wherever
your queen moves your C pawn is dropping
so you're in a bit of trouble here
so that pawn is untouchable which
explains why he decided to eliminate the
guy on the t4 here so now the knight
must retreat he's thinking about taking
on f4 with a knight so Carlsen protects
it okay so now after black castles
here's the chance to win a tempo on the
Queen and after the Queen retreats a
very nice move just d5 sort of locking
down the pawns over here and perhaps a
rook will come to the C file you'll get
some pressure and for the the pawned
that he gave up he has a very nice
position he's going to go to work on the
Queen side he's got these very nice
bishops so it's going to make blacks
life a little difficult and he has
plenty of compensation for the pawn so
black prevents the knight from ever
coming to b5 because I'm b5 the knight
would be attacking the C pawn did be
thinking about jumping into d4 so okay
also this frees up the rook in case
there was ever a situation where the
rope need to move the bishops not taking
on a7 so white gets his rook to the open
file and it's you know it's hard to see
what blacks plan is ultimately what he's
going to have to do is come up with some
sort of attack on the Kings side but it
proves very difficult in this game so he
starts off by getting his King a little
safer he puts his King in the corner and
okay as we thought before here comes the
rook putting some pressure on the C file
and okay so he gets out of the way now
he can put a rook to defend a C pawn and
again it
nice move by white he's never going to
allow black to play a move like c6 then
he's going to his bishops going to come
alive so okay also the Bishop's going to
do a good job defending the King
eventually it might park itself back on
g2 which will look like a normal fee and
cheto
so he defends the pawn and now Queen to
b3 hoping to provoke a weakness he's
hoping to make the pawn move so that he
has you know something to work with
so after black played b5 we notice some
of these light squares over on the Queen
side are a bit tender in what's going to
hopefully exploit those perhaps this
night will come back and jump into the
c6 square that's one possibility and
that's what happens right away
okay and here black has to do something
over here on the Kings side he's got to
get an attack going before you know
white strangles them on the Queen side
and okay so yeah c6 is the big focal
point for white here now black wants to
trade the LightSquared Bishop then
White's control over the light squares
won't be as relevant so should white
trade the answer is no we're fighting
for squares like c6 and okay it's worth
kicking duck the clean away now black
might be thinking of following with a
move like Bishop h3 trying to train
again but white stops um with a kind of
a cool move an unusual move but h4
creates a very unusual pawn structure
but it prevents black from trading the
LightSquared Bishop s' and the Queen is
sort of offside here she doesn't you
know really have a constructive way of
entering the Kings side okay so even
though the a pawn structure is slightly
unusual it's you know it makes a lot of
sense and now black made sort of a an
error and judgment here that this is
probably the mistake that cost him the
game he brought the knight back
the intention is you know he's going to
go bring a Knight to g4 but what he's
giving up is the c6 square so now
you'll notice you know there's some
weaknesses that black has to worry about
and so white just goes to town here he's
going to go munch up the a pond and it's
not like you can really defend it
because then you would lose your C pond
so white is going to get his pawn
maybe blacks gonna say okay while you're
getting my pond I'm bringing my troops
in here they come and I'm going to
attack you but what really happens is
now the Queen side falls apart
now that the a ponds gone the b-pawn
this week when the bee ponds gone this
will be week when the C ponds gone the D
pawn will be weak so his attack needs to
succeed over here okay so he defends the
pawn his thinking is probably if white
takes and he did he can pin the knight
but white is happy to play the move a4
he's not worried about this trade
doubling the pawns because now the C
pawn is just gonna be super weak you
know you can imagine a lot of pieces
attacking this so he's not worried about
that but all right so the knight finally
makes it to g4 and black is thinking
about some speculative sacrifices that
don't really work but that's what he's
going to try to do and want in a minute
here because otherwise if you're not
attacking me then I'm just taking your
whole Queen side and eventually you know
the past pawns that I will create over
here when I get your C pawn will win the
day for me so okay painting in the night
preventing the knight from taking the
bishop so okay the Queen backs out of
the way and what just takes the time
here to get his his Queen out of the pin
so black can go ahead and take this
bishop and maybe he should consider that
but he went in for the sacrifice here
which shouldn't really work but alright
there are some some tricks here for
example if you just take back to the
piece you're actually losing here so you
may want to pause your videos and ask
what would black play here and I'll ask
the audience what would black play in
this situation
yes you would take the bishop okay will
suppose that I take back okay I assume
you mean this pond yeah right and now
white isn't huge trouble
if you ever go to the e-file I'm going
to win your rook if you stay where
you're protecting your rook this check
is going to end your day because now
after I take back if you take then the
rook is dropping so Carlsen does have to
be a little bit careful but I'm sure he
saw this and he simply traded the knight
on g4 before taking back on h4 so black
gave up a piece and so if he doesn't
meet white White's going to win he's up
a piece so he he comes up with a way to
threaten mate but white stopped him the
move f5 and black is losing here he's
not really there's really nothing else
that can be said but white still needs
to show some pretty good technique so
it's interesting to watch black attacks
the F pond so white defends it of course
now the D pawn is falling but this is
really only a way of trading pawns
because now the knight takes on c7 and
okay to pass pawns and an extra piece
are looking pretty good for white so
we'll see the technique that Carlson
used okay here he just pinned he's never
going to be afraid to win to trade
pieces okay at some point we'll take
this guy probably first will we'll just
try to stop any of your threats all
right black stops white from playing to
move f6 it may be one day he's going to
try to dream of some sort of counter
play based on opening up the G file so
White's next move makes a lot of sense
he puts the bishop on d4 so that in some
lines if you ever do get to move g6 in
you're going to have to worry about
pressure on f6 also the bishop is useful
here might be able to block the C file
if necessary if for example there's a
rook on the C file
okay the knight on the bishop on c3
would effectively stop him from entering
the position so he brought his Queen
back extra protection of f6 and in a
minute he's going to try to get this
going but it never really works for him
so Carlsen improves his knight and now
again another very nice move he
understands g6 is coming so he just gets
his King off of the G file so very nice
so here he goes the rook is trying for
some activity so Carlson is not going to
let that happen and he blocks the C file
and all right there's just not a lot for
black to do as soon as this guy starts
rolling the game is going to be over
okay so the bishop comes in here you
know giving the rook the c4 square but
okay again now the Knights blocking is
pieces are doing a very good job
blocking out the rooks any minute now
the D pawn is going to fall so yeah
there's not a lot that can be done the
Queen just goes back and defends
everything and in just this position
here black resigned your piece down and
okay these guys are just too strong
especially the a pawn so a really nice
example from Carlsen and yeah he went on
to brilliantly win that whole tournament
very good result for him so one more
time we'll go back we got one more game
for you and we'll look at a slightly
different line that black can play so
this game was played between Gary
Kasparov and etienne back row in 2000
and again we have the scotch this was
around the time that Garry Kasparov made
this opening popular it's okay if it
gone a long time just kind of unplayed
at the top level and he didn't play it
that many times but he had very good
results with it so he you want a bunch
of games had some draws and he never
lost with the scotch and against you
know some of the world's best so this
had become popular now we were looking
at Bishop to c5 earlier but in this game
we'll look at another popular choice
from black almost as popular as Bishop
to c5 and that's Knight to f6 so if you
play the move Knight to c3
you're going to enter the the Scotch for
Knights defense so that's one
possibility but more common is to take
on c6 now it's probably unwise to take
here and let white trade on the D file
so we can expect black to take back and
okay again if you have to play a move
like Knight to c3 you're probably not
challenging black that much he's looking
to take this so the most common move
here is to push 'if I've threatening to
win the knight you know you're hoping to
make the knight move and if black is a
bit complacent we're going to get our
pieces out and Castle and have a very
pleasant position which is why black in
this position normally plays Queen to e7
attacking the pawn and so the pin
prevents us from taking the knight and
so a bit unusual if you've never seen
this is White's next move Queen to e2
breaking the pin and forcing the knight
to move so when we teach beginners we
usually tell them don't put their queen
in front of the bishops but in the
mainline Scotch here both players have
done it voluntarily so so we get this
interesting position now the knight has
to move so it's going to d5 and it's
probably to Black's benefit they both of
the Queen's here are misplaced because
it's white that needs to get this Bishop
out a little bit more than black black
often will Castle queenside in these
variations so we'll see we'll see that
in some games but let's see here
so c4 a very nice move now there's
there's two main moves what was played
in the game is the most popular so
painting the pawn also popular is you
know Knight to c6 after which this is
sort of played and you get some very
interesting positions as well but much
more common is Bishop to a6 pinning the
pond and what usually plays b3 just
having a solid Queen side also common is
a knight to d2 which has the advantage
of getting a piece out in protecting the
pawn again now the Queen will move at
some point and
the threat of taking the night will be
real but this is the most popular
usually this Bishop will go to be to
right will decide where he wants to put
this Bishop usually the Queen will move
somewhere the bishop can get out or he
won't play g3 and you'll put this bishop
on g2 so we'll will see the setup here
with g6 interesting also is a move that
a nod likes to play g5 just protecting
the f4 square so preventing white from
ever playing a move f4 so that's an
interesting line to have a look at it's
not very popular but and the nun seems
to like it here
okay black just intends to attack the
pawn again and so white gets going he's
gonna he has a majority over here so
he's going to play for an attack on the
black King if he decides to go Kings
side alright so this is a move that gets
played quite frequently and often in
these lines what white is going to do is
he's going to put his Queen on f2 to
break the pen and force the knight to
move so black did something kind of
strange and it didn't really work for
him so it might not have been the best
plan but he put his Queen on b6 which is
sort of unusual normally that's where
the night goes but he's you know he's
not letting white go through with his
plan of Queen def - if you do play this
at some point yeah you're not really we
don't have to take you you're not really
threatening to take because then you'll
you'll undo our ponds so that move
wouldn't make a lot of sense but in this
position he did break the pin and he
played Queen to e4 which is pretty nice
he's provoking the move f5 which was
played so now when he gets his Queen out
of the way where once again threatening
to win this Knight so the knight has to
move or we have to attack this work
which will lead to a series of trades so
possible was Knight to be four when
white would probably have to play a move
like King to d1 but we're getting ready
to trap this bishop or the knight sorry
with a move like this so black would
have to you know make room for the the
knight to retreat so this would have
been it
way to play instead he went for the
attack on the rook which will provoke
some trades and now here in this
position black is sort of compelled to
trade the bishops in this position with
a nice little trick this should be four
so obviously if we take this we drop our
rook but if you don't play that move if
you play Queen to b6 e six is just a
very nice move attacking the rook and
this is going to be very pleasant for
white so when you move we're going to
take here and why it's going to be very
happy here at some point you'll play
like b3 and Bishop b2 and you'll get
some some pressure going here so that
would be nice
positionally so he's kind of compelled
to trade the bishops here so that was
done all right and black did decide to
go Queen side and now this game is going
to end up with a very positional endgame
and so white played a very nice move
here
c5 sort of locking down on the the dark
squares here is you know black is going
to at some point going to have to try to
break out but you'll notice with
LightSquared bishop s' he's going to
want to have all this pawns on dark
squares so black can trade the bishops
here if he wants to in the game he
preferred to stay close to his King
worrying that okay there might be some
tricks on the Queen side here at some
point possible was this sort of
continuation and the endgame is pleasant
for white but he decided to keep the
bishops on the board so he went to kind
of a useless square but he's hoping to
keep his Bishop where he can protect his
King so now in this position white is
happy to go into a rook and Bishop
ending so because he's going to have
some some targets perhaps he can bring a
rook to attack this pawn there's this
guy and we'll see some really nice play
here okay so we get this position and if
black wants you know he can trade lots
of pieces here but white won't be too
uncomfortable he'll even be willing to
trade the rooks in such a position
because the bishop endgame is just going
to be favorable with all of these guys
stuck on light squares it's going to
give us Bishop something to attack so
that was not played instead he got his
his King out another nice move so notice
how all of his pawns are on dark squares
and okay I plan like h5 and taking on g6
will be a really pleasant one for white
you can put this rook on the edge file
and then he can create a weakness on g6
so after the bishop was kicked away this
is a you know not exactly what black
wants to do here with his pawns now the
bishop is extra silly but uh okay so
that's what he played and yeah so black
now puts more pawns on light squares now
these guys are stuck here but he was
really worried about the move h5 which
would have just been fantastic for for
white
so now we'll see a really excellent
technique here in the endgame he's got a
lot of targets you know you can imagine
a rook coming to g3 attacking this pawn
rook switching over attacking the a pond
and it'll be easy for white to improve
his King he just has a nice easy peasy
plan of running to the d4 square so
that's going to happen first he attacks
the pawn and an interesting way to
defend perhaps he's worried in some
lines with with the rook is on g8
that'll be some tricks occasionally
where if this rook moves then Bishop
takes h5 will be possible so these are
going to be potential threats coming up
in the future so he decides to defend
his pawn laterally alright and now
before another nice move preventing
black from doing any you know breaking
out with a 5 so he's he's really
stopping black from doing anything and
he's running out of plans whereas white
he has a lot of moves and you know he is
he's a lot of waiting moves he can just
improve his pieces get this guy into the
game so that's what we see now black
might be thinking of playing a 5 again
so rook to be 1 so in the case of a 5
now he can play
move like b5 and if you trade this is
going to be a lot of fun for white so
instead a six okay you know this is as
horrid as it gets you know this this guy
is is the worst so okay he's going to
put his rook here on a three and black
has absolutely no counter play at all
now he can't move and white is just
going to maneuver around as much as he
wants and yeah a lot of fun okay
so sometimes the rook will be able to
shift and it's nice being white here
because your pieces can go back and
forth keep creating threats on both
sides of the board waiting for some sort
of Zug Swain situation and okay so black
has nothing to do he's just waiting so
the King improves and okay so but white
still has to win now they they repeat a
few times you know getting closer to the
time control and now white comes up with
a way to win so he attacks here and now
this was the last move of the game white
has a nice tactical move here based on
where the you know we got our rooks we
got our Bishop and we got this possible
deflection so what move was played here
and again you may want to pause your
video at home because it's a nice pretty
move upon e6 is possible this is
probably good I think what do you played
was a little bit better but yeah your
point is that you're you're breaking
through right here and yeah I think this
is is is reasonable enough okay now
these guys are both weak but the game
continuation was even stronger I'm
counting on you you're furiously trying
to figure it out I can tell
so not the deflection immediately but he
he kept it in mind in the move that he
played was Bishop takes h5 a crusher and
here black resigned and we'll try to
understand why there's two ways to take
if we take with the rook will now take
it and now what will white play yeah so
the pawn check and alright yes if you
take this you lose your rook and if you
don't take it I'll check you again
eventually you're going to have to take
it and you know you're gonna lose a rook
and this guy is useless so the game
would be over and it's very similar if
you take with your pawn
I can trade once and now we get sort of
the same situation where you're gonna
have to take my pawn in and lose your
rook so an excellent positional
masterpiece by garry kasparov
and so yeah there's a lot of openings in
the future I'd like to to do you guys
sent me so many possible openings that
it's going to take me like a year to get
through them all which is good because
this is the last episode of the year so
we got a whole new year coming up so
hopefully in a 2016 I'll see you guys
again keep sending in all your comments
your feedback suggestions for for new
openings like subscribe and I'll see you
next time thank you guys
Oh